Garth how was this project presented to
you for Lyon I was at Sundance Film
Festival with top of the lake actually
and the producers of that in Canning and
Emile Sherman and I were just getting
together and they had just read this
article about Saru story I just can't
just come out and they just said oh my
god this is so you goth you should read
it so I raced up to my Lodge and I read
the article and totally fell in love a
ceruse story I said guys is is fantastic
so they said okay well we'll go and try
get the rights to it and so the next day
they started trying to find out who had
the rights to his story and and I think
about a month later Emil had secured the
rights to the project and we started
getting into it so had you read his book
in the meantime the book hadn't come out
at all so this is very early on so it
was just a it was it was it was an
article in the press so to come out went
through had just found his mother so
that's all we had read so when we
started when we got the rights we
started to research the project his book
came out somewhere along the line after
that and then at what point are you
actually sitting down meeting Saru maybe
even going to India so as soon as we got
the rights the first thing I said is I
need to go to India and start retracing
his steps and and feeling this feeling
his story and coincidentally at the time
Australian 60 minutes was doing a an
article on Saru and they were taking the
adopted mother sue to make the birth
mother Kamla for the first time so I was
there when they were filming that and
that was my first day in my research
trip so I suddenly kind of thrust very
deeply into this family's life and
experience and yeah kind of saw some
crazy things that was amazing
so that was my first day in the research
and then from that point on I kind of
retraced young Sarah's journey I went on
some trains I went to Calcutta I went to
the orphanages I wandered around the
streets at night imagining what I'd be
like for him to be living on these
streets I mean I have children myself so
the whole that holux journey for me was
very impactful
and then I went to Hobart and metal of
his contemporary friends hung out with
John Sarah's father and just try to
immerse myself in in their life as much
as possible and what time frame is that
that you're actually kind of sinking in
Sarah's world oh look I probably spent I
think the trip was like three weeks
probably and then I would continue on
with some conversations and phone calls
skypes and then I would revisit some of
these places again as well okay and then
you somehow presented this idea to Luke
or how did this yes so I started the
research trip and then the three of us
Amelie and myself we started to look at
different writers and we all really
loved Luke and so we engaged with Luke
and at a certain point he became
officially engaged with the project and
then we quickly sent him on a same trip
I did so at least we could be on the
same page when we got together to talk
about the film great and then in terms
of actors I know you'd said previously
that there's so many great ones but you
wanted ones that you knew could carry
the emotionality of so many of the
scenes you can talk about what you were
looking for specifically in terms of
that emotion well first and foremost I
needed people to connect to the story in
a way that I felt would honor the film I
mean it's just it's such an emotional
film that no one can dial it in do you
not I mean so you know you might be
presented with a list is but if they're
not totally passionate about it I don't
want them do you not I mean so they had
to be very passionate about the story
I'm each character had a different need
so for instance what I loved about
Nicole Kidman for example is that
there's kind of a strength and Nicole
Kidman that I saw in sue this was a lot
of similarities I could start to see
emotionally so I don't know a lot of
things started become quite apparent to
me when I was dreaming the characters
and meeting the actors that it it became
quite obvious who was right what what is
it about the passion and an actor well
how do you how can you tell are there
are there phrases is there body language
just even when you know that they can
nail the performance but in terms of
really being committed like that I just
care about it I can talk about it from
their own point of view they can own it
they can have an opinion they they're
deep in the material so that's really
important you know when I met Nicole in
New York to talk about the role she just
spoke about it in such a deep way and
how it related to her life and imagine
that and we just had this such deep
conversation so that's a place you're
starting from I mean of course the
performances are going to be amazing you
know because we're going to go to such
deep and honest places together so yeah
it's really important I think first day
of shooting where was this the first
week were night shoots with sunny
five-year-old sunny in the train station
okay and I understand that sunny this is
one of his first this was one of his
first acting roles at that time well
yeah he's yeah unbelievable just five oh
and so you saw how many children to find
a thousand boy
we passed about four to five months in
three three cities in India and then we
would look at that we look at those
tapes coming in on Dropbox every week
and then we created a shortlist of maybe
a hundred to two hundred children and
then a group of us went over to India
and did these acting workshops for about
a week or two weeks just trying to find
our kids so then so you start with the
night shoots at the train station and
how was that especially because sunny is
so young and this is one of his I mean
it must have been overwhelming for him
this huge crew or I don't know yeah I
mean it was we're all just learning the
language and learning how we all work
together so you know you just stumble
through it and the minute you get it
like maybe you just find a moment that's
really special you just know that you're
on the right path and you just build
upon those experiences and confidence
and that you know the way you move
together as a crew becomes easier and so
very quickly you just tune into what the
film is going to be but you know up at
that point your eyes imagining
how it could be and that's all
hypothetical until you're literally
making the thing so the reality of
working with a child working in India
all that comes to a head at that moment
and so it's kind of terrifying exciting
at the same time we were asking Gregg
how it was to be there with this camera
and he said that actually most of the
people around were used to productions
being around there can you talk about
maybe using some of the people that were
maybe not extras they were actual
talented people yeah look I mean I think
Calcutta was easier to shoot in and say
Mumbai because they're just not I mean
they're not they're not as exposed to
movies as people in Mumbai so you know
they get curious but a lot of the times
people they've got to catch the train
they're going to move on so every 20
minutes you'd get a new wave of people
so if someone started to look there's a
certain point they've got to go catch
the train so I don't know it kind of
worked for us we would you know we would
definitely have extras there that we
would put into the foreground and then
have live crowds in the background like
the ticket box scene we were when when
he's being kind of you know ignored and
shoved out of the way when he's trying
to ask for help we we controlled the
first three or four ticket boxes and
then the rest down the end was just real
tickets being sold so because we're
working in live locations so we kind of
got the scale that way just working very
cleverly within the within real spaces
now are you shooting a lot of it sort of
in chronological order in terms of his
life I mean pretty much I mean we shot
India first and we shot Australia second
it was almost chronological we shot in
Calcutta all the stuff in Calcutta first
and then we moved out to the villages so
it wasn't wasn't that linear but I mean
Dev Patel 'he's first scene was when he
met his mother and the end of the movie
oh wow okay so there was very nonlinear
moments but I think by shooting India
first we were able to learn a lot from
that and take take the textures and the
colors and the visual language that we
created there
into the contemporary story so I think
was great shooting in your first Garth
taking just a little bit of a detour in
terms of the questions for you what were
some mistakes in your career early on
that you made that you make sure that
you don't replicate in terms of whether
it's just working with a large crew in
an outdoor location things that maybe in
the beginning you weren't sure of and
now having had so many productions under
your belt you're more aware of oh you do
absolutely learn from mistakes a lot of
them are directorial mistakes some of
them are production mistakes but the
number one rule I have is always trust
our instinct your instinct is never
wrong so if you have a bad feeling about
someone you're about to employ or cast
or a location or scene that's not right
it there is a problem and to acknowledge
that and talk about it that's definitely
one of the things that I live by the
other thing is you just have to be very
prepared and never assume anything like
so always see the set before you shoot
it always see the Wardrobe before you
see it on the actors on the day like
never assume anything is gonna be okay
on the day it's just a number one rule
that I have some I'm always making sure
I see everything before we shoot and if
you I'm well prepared and have a good
dialogue with everybody around me and
you follow those rules and generally you
should be okay so when someone throws
the the don't worry line it'll be fine
which I know someone who works from
their intuition gets as well what do you
say to that I've done it a few times and
it has been okay but I've also done that
it's been terrible so you just go by
that rule no matter what uh-huh even
when I'm absolutely exhausted like in
the last movie we just finished shooting
and we were traveling to a new location
and we could go and visit the set but
was like another hour and a half
diversion and I was exhausted I want to
go to bed and I said just got to check
it out so it's just one of those rules
that I have just got to see it before
you shoot it what was the largest crew
you were working with and what location
was that
in terms of lyin yeah
the largest crew I mean probably I mean
probably the one of the biggest things
we did in India was closing down the
Howrah bridge so that's never been done
before and it's the sequence where
little sue escapes from the child
Snatchers and he runs out of the train
station and emerges onto the bridge and
it's kind of overcome by the scale of
the bridge he's never seen anything like
that before and he's almost too afraid
to cross it because of the scale of it
and he then goes to the side and sees
the bother shrine so that bridge we had
to get permission to control that so he
had obviously had a lot of traffic
management at either end of the bridge
so that was probably the biggest
logistical thing that we did and then
there are other times we're shooting
something quite small but we had
thousands of people looking at us and
that kind of consumed a lot of resources
just trying to control the crowd as well
but it was fairly simple shoot like we
didn't use any lighting very small
amounts of lighting we shot with two
cameras I mean it's all pretty basic
stuff how did you deal with sound it's a
good question Nakul our sound recordist
in India I think was a bit of a genius
he may have even been nominated for an
Oscar I think at some point but he was
just a wonderful sound recordist and
you'll even notice the actors when
they're in a scene if they hear a train
horn they'll just pause and then they'll
continue the line after the train so
like everyone's very aware of sound but
you couldn't hide from it we had to do a
lot of cleanup but the sound of course
was very good is extremely good so when
you're on set for lion are you mostly
working with the crew or are you mostly
working with the actors where's your
attention mostly football oh it's it's
it's kind of everything the minute I
arrived on set you say good morning
everyone and I the first place I go is a
the Wardrobe truck so the makeup truck
so I meet my actors in the morning say
good morning and make sure that there
comfortable with the day ahead of them
and it's the first thing I do a second
morning to everybody and then often the
first hour of the morning you're with
the crew because the actors are still
preparing so you're you know and then I
sit with my DP and we have 10 minutes
together and I talked about and the ad
and we just talked about the mornings
work and what we're trying to achieve
and then we walk to set and then we then
we all go off independently and work
with our crew so there's definitely a
rhythm that I have when I'm working that
seems to have worked for me in terms of
Google Earth how familiar were you with
it I mean I know it's been around what a
decade I guess before actually delving
into the shots and figuring out the
older version of it yes a Google Earth I
mean I use all the time for location
searching anyway in commercials and so
Google Earth is a tool that I use as
much as I do with Microsoft Word but you
know I think what was I mean it's it's a
risk having anything computerized in
your movie I mean there's nothing more
boring than looking at a mobile phone or
a computer screen in a film but I think
in this instance it was kind of really
exciting to to take the power of his
past and his yearning and his you know
all of that into these computer into
these computer images you know of into
Google Earth and to see these maps
passing through so it suddenly became
very loaded and interesting and haunting
and the fact that it was low resolution
and it didn't work very fast the kind of
the texture of it for me was like memory
and so suddenly something got quite
excited about the software and how it
became this strange window into his past
so it was it was great challenge to kind
of bring that software to life in a way
that was meaningful now did you actually
go to the Google headquarters in
Mountain View no no no we no just not
all we did really is we we had to get
their approval obviously because we were
showing their software in a film and
they were fine with that and then we
asked them to help us you know get the
software back to that period so that was
and we're
and figure out a way how do we get the
old naps back as well because everything
is sort dated now so high-resolution
that we had to kind of yeah D take it go
backwards when you're making a film
about someone's life and you've met this
person you've met their family
you've traveled to their homeland how
much pressure responsibility do you feel
huge amounts yeah I did documentary once
in my early years and really felt that
responsibility in a visceral way and I
mean you know it's something I'm very
conscious of and so you know that's why
I really did have to spend a lot of time
and I think I said to sue look maybe
we're not gonna get the story perfectly
right like a documentary you know you
just can't you know it's kind of a
compressed version of it but I hope that
I get it emotionally right for you and I
hope that you feel proud about the
message it comes out of it out of out of
your story because that's that's really
what I was hoping to get out of it so it
kind of simplifies what you're trying to
represent for them so yeah that's yeah
it's a huge responsibility at the end of
the day which scene of lion are you most
proud of so many beautiful scenes and
it's such a journey but look I do love
the scene with Sue and Saru just the two
hander which he talks about the vision
of the ghost and how she could have had
children I just thought that was when I
was filming that I was unaware of where
I was I was so like I was lost in her
performance so um that's pretty exciting
when that happens